rodman numero 15 quando culto oggi ci
siamo passati più tardi perché ragazzino
lasciando le piccole siamo devastati da
poco più di metà di questa esperienza vi
prego dateci la forza andare avanti
alzate levati al cielo come quella gente
da ma mettete un laicato video con lo
short e un po provati nei sicuramente
fare youtube con ogni giorno il loto il
premier è una figata a stare pure sul
social viola ad un e di mercoledì
venerdì e domenica dalle 19 è un'altra
fi catona però io mi ritroverò in questa
esperienza cadavere si sa che natale un
po così ho deciso di premiarmi alle
spalle di tutti con un cristo
andiamo pulito la giornata si è
congedata di magia siamo nelle mani dei
rigori in cucina mastroianni cosa ci
cucini quello che c'è pomodori del pesto
bottiglia totalmente mani in pasta fatta
a mano e poi a quota sei bravo a
tagliare i pomodori o un'elezione
davvero arrivati io vi chiedo veramente
scusa per lo spaghetto di pantaloni
palla questo crispi miglior panino
fammi sapere quel vostro panino
preferito per marilyn mac ma il panino
un migliore e che supera il crispi del
gran chris chimet bacon che hanno tolto
dal commercio firmiamo una petizione per
farlo tornare fra mettetelo proprio come
panino e chesta sempre basta questa
farsa guido rimetteteli ovviamente le
basse come piazza la regina del pianeta
ma parlando
ma tu non usi olio non maison e se
prosciugato tranquilla ci sta la
valentina il suo desiderio di far valer
g star la regina del pianeta
la verità è che siamo tutti
letteralmente sparita noi non sappiamo
cosa vuol dire stare sempre nel web
giusto seguitemi tutti fermo mangiami in
piedi e io non sono un fatto scoprire
così perde tanto la bontà del cristo ci
ho capito prima di essere che
fondamentalmente ma sinceramente mi
sembra molto meno importante come
fattore il misfatto altri però famosi di
nuovo grande causate da un attimo
inquadratura di merda ma valentina a
regina del web non ci riprenderà ma di
cucinare c'è chi è un targa e chi no e
ad esempio la pasta la prendo bollente
così quando la rivedrà la faccia notti e
scotto 40 e morbida
certo penso io ma qua io come faccio a
cucinare riprendere la rigiriamo il tuo
sugo invece crudo
allora vediamo un po che sotto motori
l'amante qatada pentolone del manteniamo
dalla acqua di cottura fila di tenere
questa sembra la puntata di cucina
buttata da ragazzi e ne ha viste le
puntate di ragazzi valentina non sa cosa
vuol dire cha kcal h cioè non faccia
vuol dire valentina aiutate figura
guarda adesso è buona certo è iniziata
la caccia a calcio con gli amici a
karaci bambini sacal a qaim boldin cazzo
bastava che lo dicessi in questo modo
quello petti la tecnica per mantecare
questo proprio un cazzo delle romano
damonte gara
bravo per i no si muove
bastava è pronta
mangiamo non so voi ma io sto passando
aggiornate a mangiare
della casa stiamo mangiando in maniera
interi con da domenica c'è stata pure
alle 19 sul social viola una puntata di
pro compensa nella quale sono morto
trattato completamente che ha ucciso
paura a salire su quella di lance dalle
urla in faccia a faccia ma lavora
presente della banca
posso di comunque non sapete cos'è
chagall a cannes alla standa
incompetenza razzante penso che abbia
fatto una figuraccia di fronte un canale
che vorrei una sommossa popolare contro
valentino che odio nei commenti però c'è
io scriverei shaka l'aca valentina 58
parigina jacques arata guarda il mio
occhio valentina guarda al ginocchio
valentina se non lo sai neanche che vuol
dire quando rosanero ragazzi non segue
il canale è una talpa qua dentro
vuole solo fregarci non ha visione anche
del pool e travis e riposte rinnovamento
e mi ha insegnato gianmarco non ci credo
ma pure nella pasta ma la buttava era un
bicchiere pieno d'acqua è la regina del
web non conosce di niente e viene in
questo canale
non so che dire chiudiamo un'acqua di
roma l'acqua ragazzi la regina del web
l'ha fatta grossa questa volta e tutti
mi hanno scritto e vedove dedicarmi ai
un nemico valentina non avrebbe dovuto
sono sempre stato gentile con vale c'è
sempre stato un rapporto amorevole amore
odio
è il legno ha lanciato un guanto puoi
prendere un altro bicchiere d'acqua e
amico mio mi spiace questa qui nel cesso
lo sai quale del discorso solitamente mi
sveglio prima di testa ma io l'ho detto
più tardi ma io posso sempre parti dopo
quello che tu fai prima domani entrano
in camera tua questa vasta immangiabile
a rimediare i miei peccati di gola sono
già 40 minuti che sto camminando attorno
monti e termini classico che vogliamo
fare arrivare a orte mangia ogni cosa
che trova per terra
cioè mi sembra me che mi amano qualsiasi
cosa anche lui come quasi ma che quella
donna di chi è quella donna del mistero
sta andando in tribunale bocca al lupo
combatti per la legge tempo di prendere
aria farò 5 chilometri a piedi per
arrivare in tribunale perché bisogna un
po di passeggiare prendo anche una
laurea in giurisprudenza per scappare da
questo posto andare anch'io in tribunale
qualsiasi cosa mi auguri elmo che bello
stare con voi il guglielmo cha tu bello
bello
dall'uomo che cazzo si rialza ragazzi
volevo regalarvi questo momento non so
perché ma
volevano male io spero che non mi prendo
un malanno sono morto del capo click
e puoi toglierti la maglietta per
favorire ce n'è bisogno con casse cela
gianmarco senza ora bisogna dare
qualcosa a questo canale assolutamente
negativo dai succedere che fate
rafficato brava graziola stavo
screditando perché lei che è una falsa
amica e cioè che cosa stavo difendendo
the vuole bene solo per la tua fama non
sono un momento buio
qui c'è un piatto di pasta verde che ho
cucinato con i miei sapienti mani io
sono riversate rammendava di inserirlo
tanto leggero perché abbiamo un sacco in
questi giorni in cucina ecco vittima ma
so niente oggi nomadi realtà naga
scusate non è michele rabbia
effettivamente aperto ma una troppo
calda ora che veramente siamo stati così
con un pochino solamente pieno perché
abbiamo mangiato comunque lei non sa
cosa voglia dire shaka la carica
veramente piene di tutto il plesso
grande jam bluff non sono anche disposto
a prendermi in acqua per te parole
fortissime guarda ci sarà il gioco io
prendo quest'albero zero si regala tutti
ormai odiamo quest'albero ho deciso che
per questo natale per tutti i nostri
follower insegnerò una stella cometa di
carta igienica una stella cometa di
natale da poter giocare a casa con tutte
le vostre famiglie seguite neal il
grande artista per questa ricetta delle
stelle di natale ne ho bisogno di un
rotolo di carta igienica un avvocato
duro messaggio bravo bravo una musica
d'olio e un foglio chiaro
[Musica]
faccio uno stecchino veloce la valletta
accendi questa luce è sì siamo con i
momenti di tensione con questa non
funziona deve avere più peso
vuoi chiedere una molletta alla vicina
[Musica]
così sarebbe turbato gli animi
per prima cosa per fare questa ricetta
abbiamo bisogno di me vale per chi dice
che i soldi pubblici tenere carta da
culo e una molletta viene ancora meglio
se abbiamo le mollette pure pesanti si
mette la molletta così per la coda è
lunga e questo mi aggiravo più la coda
lunga più navale e il presidente pronta
la valletta della signora stella di
natale esprime un desiderio bravo cosa
di portare principe ma meglio non
riportava che riporta gli era dotato di
ragazzi si è rotta si allontana a parte
che la mollezza de merda però capito ma
che le fasi di lavoro bisogna sempre di
la verità l'onestà paga sempre piene di
rho signora stava facendo le stelle di
natale che mi si è rotta serio faccia
del pigmento signora mia mi dispiace
voluto cadere
[Musica]
la stella di natale come non mortifica
mangiato la foglia che è un pezzo di
pane di donna un pezzo di pane tv cena
una donna un pezzo di pane e sono
tornato quando meschina figura con
leggero bozzo che si intravede però la
mutanda stringe quindi non è troppo
bruciare lascia intravedere un gluteo e
prendendo il camper sul posto li
ricevuto corpose toruk matto è tornato
cavalcatore di toru se sito di non
doverti relativo a riposare di là ti
possa dare una crema lingerie scia
rilascia le vostre creme così l'immagine
di obama dalla star vicina se le donne
non hanno la barbie aspetti che
finalmente direttamente ma io non so che
cosa mi stia facendo e quanto più da
questa telecamera tutti stavo per tutto
che è meglio degli allievi
no non farà mai meglio degli allenamenti
jabri non secondo sembra che non stai
all'interno di questa casa alessandro ci
metti una musica hawaiana
il rumore del mare ti prego facci
sognare e qualche gabbiano la canzone
del natale road cup profittabilità e tra
parentesi non è ancora mangiato tu però
adesso la porta sarà abbastanza fredda
che fai questo ripeto 3 aver fatto uno
spuntino le vostre prova a indovinare
inizia per crispi e finisce per mac
bacon esiste qualcos'altro
non volevo cantare li società un goldoni
sono passato davanti a quelle m gialla
che che diceva ne vuoi la md mi vuoi ti
ho detto sì mi piace detto ciò abbiamo
pure twitch tra tipo nura manco da
quanto saremo sì ma versano
levigatissimo ci vediamo lì alle 19
notarli poniamo di cospargerci di questo
liquido angelico che mi permetterà di
essere meraviglioso per niente stanco
riposa tissimo per stasera avrei di
sonno ogni notte girano domani in cui
non blocca alle 14